so this morning and all the way until
wednesday afternoon around 5. it's going
to be one lane in either direction right
here at las vegas boulevard spring
mountain
all the way down to sahara so we're kind
of used to seeing this cones everywhere
construction workers and of course
they're keeping everybody safe out here
so pack some extra time and patience
with you if you're headed down into this
area of the resorts corridor between
spring mountain and sahara so this
construction is all to replace the
pavement and stripping along the las
vegas boulevard
if you work at any of the resorts or
headed there for a staycation don't
worry clark county says the driveways of
the resorts in the area will remain open
you should also expect longer traffic
signal wait times at las vegas boulevard
inner sections with
fashion show drive convention center
drive elvis presley boulevard and circus
circus drive lane closures and these
traffic changes will continue throughout
the fall and again if you want to avoid
the las vegas boulevard you can take the
parallel streets to las vegas boulevard
you can take sammy davis jr or you can
take a paradise but again if you have to
come through this area again pack some
more extra time with you five ten
minutes pack some patience and be sure
that you're remaining cautious and alert
because these cones can be a little
difficult to navigate reporting from the
las vegas boulevard bianca holman 8 news
now